this is something a little different
i don't think anybody has covered this
okay because one of our viewers tanner
wrote to me and said hey david big fan
of the show
after seeing many of the ridiculous
responses to mask mandates across the
country i decided to see if this is
happening at my local school board i
watched the most recent meeting and was
not disappointed i have attached a video
in which a middle school student and her
dad both quote hitler during their
anti-mask presentations to the school
board this is really wacky stuff okay
i'm going to play this for you this is
the thompson school district
they claim to be the 17th largest school
district in colorado
they claim to have about 15 000 students
under their purview
you really have to see this this is
daughter and then dad who quote hitler
in their opposition to masking and the
crowd cheers it's crazy this is
charlotte and thomas we're starting with
charlotte here
uh
this is very depressing let's take a
look and by the way i apologize about
the audio quality it's it's very harsh
hi my name is charlotte k
i am from birthing i would like to start
my address with a quote from a famous
politician
he alone who owns the youth gains the
future okay the famous politician she's
referring to is adolf hitler
just so people know quoting hitler
i was a student at turner middle school
i say was because i had to leave your
school district because of how your
teachers were treating
the second week i was there you made a
mask mandate i did not wear a mask
because i have medical conditions that
make it so i can't wear masks
and because of that i was segregated and
sent to the library
when i attempted to use my rights to
speak freely i read the 14th and 15th
amendment my constitution was ripped out
of my hand and when i tried to
video what the staff were doing the
teacher took my phone i mean is this so
the sad thing here is right all of this
language about my rights were taken away
i was trying to cite amendments from the
constitution
a kid doesn't come up with this stuff by
themselves and you'll see when the dad
comes up exactly where it's coming from
is this a form of child abuse i mean you
know 14th amendment
uh granting all persons born and
naturalized in the u.s a guarantee of
equal protection 15th amendment the
right of citizens to vote shall not be
denied or abridged on the basis of race
color or previous condition of servitude
what masks guys come on and and she
continues then just make my day even
better the teacher said i was a terrible
person and i was a horrible child
when
then she told me i was going to kill
everyone in school and to quote the same
politician again
if you tell a big enough fly and tell
freaking enough you it will be believed
the same politician that's adolf hitler
again that's she's quoting hitler
you say that you're supposed to keep a
student safe and protect us from the big
bad bullies
but you and your teachers are bullying
me and
all those other students in the district
how does that work
all of your students left be a lot of
your students left because of those
actions when i tried to show myself my
504 form
the teachers took it and ripped it to
pieces destroying my property
when i was in school i had to go home
multiple days because i had massive
headaches due to the masks
the classroom was and the classroom
being above 90 degrees when i used to
love school but now i don't
you have room in school for me
and fortunately it's too late it's too
late for me
but i will fight for all the other kids
in your school district including my
older sister
i hope you're happy now that you ruined
my my love for school
and one last time to quote uh the famous
politician adolf hitler when diplomacy
ends
war begins thank you for all your
consideration
[Applause]
so quoting hitler three times there now
i i have i'm not making fun of this girl
i see her as a victim
i see her as a victim
probably of this guy the dad okay here
comes the dad we're gonna pick up his
comments uh in progress as i guess we we
might say when they do teaching we have
a problem
we have a problem when we have board
members family and friends calling in to
further their agenda
that problem starts here
that problem starts with this board a
board who refuses to believe the
children when they are mistreated a
board who sold our children into mass
mandates for 18 million dollars
how much will it cost to sell our
children into mandatory vaccines
what else are you willing to sell our
children into
how many children have to be mistreated
abused or assaulted before the board is
willing to look into an incident
your mission statement is mindless
drivel
it is here a lip service to this
community that makes you feel good about
what you do
i have lost face on this board and based
on your staff and your actions you do
not have architecture i assume he means
he lost faith in the board not lost face
losing face to something different
children's best interest at heart
with that said i call for the immediate
resignation of everyone on this board a
lot of resignation people just
everybody's calling for resignations
these days we have no confidence in you
we have no trust in you and you have not
shown one ounce of diplomacy and like my
daughter said when there is no diplomacy
there is war
and even staring down the members of the
school board there uh so so like father
like daughter
both quoting hitler in their anti-mask
screeds um again
i see
the daughter as a victim
uh and i see uh this all really i mean
we
we can't attack this kid this kid got
the idea of being like this from
somewhere and you see exactly where it
came from this is really sad stuff
uh and unfortunately
these types of presentations are likely
not going away anytime soon let me know
your thoughts find me on twitter at
deepakman you can submit
submit videos of your local school board
meeting if you want to info
davidpakman.com we'll cover them
one of our sponsors is all form hands
down the easiest way to custom build
your own sofa you choose the premium
fabric you want you choose the sofa size
shape color even the color of the legs
you can customize every aspect of your
new sofa to make sure it's the perfect
fit for your home i got my first
all-form sofa a year ago i just got a
second one which is really exciting
these really are the sofas i would have
bought for my home even if all form was
not a sponsor you really can't beat the
quality the modern minimal design the
sofas are spill stain and scratch proof
you can buy one piece and start with
that and then buy more seats and
accessories to add on later shipping is
fast and free you get a hundred days to
decide if you want to keep the sofa it
comes with a forever warranty and you'll
get twenty percent off when you go to
all form dot com slash pacman the link
is right underneath this video